المسلم به مؤكدا انه لا يمكن
لاحد منع طهران من هذا الحق. تفي
على الاستخبارات الامريكية بعد
استهداف الدفاع الجوي اليوناني
بين انقرة واثينا. قال الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي في
امر مخطط له من الداخل والخارج.
بطلتها سيدة اوكرانية دخلت بهوية
ليبيا ارتفاع حصيلة ضحايا
اشتباكات طرابلس الى اثنين
الهدوء. وبعد يومين من
الاشتباكات المتواصلة في العاصمة
ومحيطها، وان القصف طال مناطق
تضم الوقود النووي. بعد شهور من
بوتين بقدراته السياسية. ولكن في
حال لعبت الجزائر دور المنقذ
والفرنسية والاسبانية والالمانية
عليها للبحث عن بدائل للغاز
بالدم. نفديك يا جزائر هكذا
قالها الجزائريون في وجه ماكون
الثلاثة الاشهر الاخيرة توالت
الزيارات الامريكية والايطالية
غير معروفة. يليها تجدد
للاشتباكات المسلحة في البصرة
الخضراء وتهريبه الى جهة مجهولة
بعد اقتحام القصر الحكومي نيران
بين انصار الصدر والحشد. حسب
مصادر ميدانية لاذاعة مونتي
وثلاثين ومائة وتسعة وخمسين
مصابا. وكان رئيس حكومة الوحدة
التي تخلت عنها الشركة الروسية
في الماضي. قالت وزارة الدفاع
الحشد والصدر وسقوط اثني عشر
ضحايا والعدد في تزايد. الكاظمي
السلام تعلن حماية المتظاهرين.
لتتلقى زخات من الرصاص من جهات
بغزارة الى المنطقة الخضراء وبعد
ساعات اشتباكات مسلحة بين انصار
كيرب قائلا هي رسالة واضحة.
الجيش الامريكي سيبحر ويحلق
هنا تصريح رسمي من مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي وعلى لسان جون
ان الانشطة تتضمن اختراق سبع
طائرات صينية لخط الوسط الفاصل
تايوان وامام اعين الصينيين
فماذا انتم فاعلون? حيث نقلت
وعشرين طائرة وثماني سفن صينية
تنفذ انشطة حول تايوان. واضافت
صرحت حينها انها ستدخل بسفونها
الحربية الى تايوان ها هي تدخل
يوجه بحماية المتظاهرين. وفتح
تحقيق عاجل ومنع استخدام الرصاص
ليرد عليهم كي يستثير غضبهم
بكلمة واحدة. ميرسي ميرسي
سوء ومكروه. الجزائر بين نارين.
اشخاص متجمهرون يهتفون بالروح
تنذر بحرب وشيكة. لمن يتابعنا.
الا تتذكرون حديثنا السابق عندما
من اسعاره. ليرد مجموعة ناشطين
بريطانيين وقاموا بتحطيم محطات
الجوي مع تحليق طائراتها الميك
تسعة وعشرين الروسية لحين تسلم
طائرات امريكية بديلة. فبماذا
سيرد بوتين الرد جاء من رمضان
دخان الحرب اذ وصل دخان اوكرانيا
الى جارتها سلوفاكيا لتعلن
بولندا وجمهورية تشيك المجاورتان
انهما ستقومان بحماية مجالها
الاعلان وكانه اشبه بوضع الزيت
على النار. انصار الصدر يتوافدون
عسكري صيني العراق يغلي. الصدر
يعتزل السياسة كانت البداية بهذا
ويعمل حيثما يسمح لنا القانون
الدولي بذلك عبور سفينتين في
اخترقت واشنطن تايوان للمرة
الثالثة بزيارة مسؤوليها اذ انها
اعين المعجبات. فلا تغرنكم هذه
المناظر الجميلة او الملامح
اقرب من حسناوات روسيا. ولم
يترأس الطاولة بل اقترب اكثر
وضعت ماكرون في موقف محرج ليصغر
بوتين من حجمها اليوم حتى يكون
طاولة كييب الى طاولة بوتين
الشهير هي نفسها الطاولة التي
الروسي ديمتري ميدفيديف ان موسكو
مستعدة للحوار مع الرئيس
مستمر وماكرون يتلقى صفعة محرجة
من الجزائر. شروط روسية جديدة.
فما هي الخطوات الجديدة لواشنطن
تجاه تايوان? جاه تايوان.
الهادئ لم يهدأ فالمعدات
العسكرية لا تتوقف والاختراقات
بذلك بل انها تحرق في اليوم
الواحد ما قيمته اكثر من عشرة
التعذيب الاقتصادي باختصار شديد.
روسيا تحرق الغاز واوروبا تحترق
البريطاني يحذر من ازمة الطاقة
وان فواتير التدفئة في الشتاء قد
حرب تم توثيقها حسب تصريحهم.
وهنا جونسون رئيس الوزراء
تصريحات نقلها التليفزيون الرسمي
ان التقنية النووية حق ايران
تفقد البريطانيين ليأتي الرد من
شركة جاز بروم الروسية. الغاز
لطائرات تركية كانت في مهمة
تابعة للناتو اندلاع ازمة جديدة
مزورة. فضيحة اختراق امني جديد
لمنتجع الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب في ولاية فلوريدا.
كيف ستؤثر هذه الفضيحة برأيكم
بوعدها مع بكين وتدخل بسلاحها
لتايوان ورد صيني معتاد ضعيف.
السياسية لترسل اليهم وزير
الخارجية الروسي سيرجي لافروف
الوطنية في ليبيا عبدالحميد
دبيبا قال ان العدوان على طرابلس
شديدة تخطط الحكومة الالمانية
لتأمين وحدة شركة في المانيا
الاحداث والتطورات. بعد تخلي
روسيا عنها ودخولها ازمة طاقة
الليبية اعلنت وزارة الصحة
المقالة من قبل البرلمان في
لاوروبا كيف سترد روسيا اتمنى
منكم وضع الاجابة في تعليق.
ونحن باسم فريق قناة شاهد لتعرف
ندعو ان يحفظ الله العراق من كل
مضيق تايوان خطط له منذ فترة
طويلة. وقد صرحت علنا قبل
الروسية ان القوات الاوكرانية
تستمر في قصف محطة النووية
الحي ويعلن حالة الطوارئ القصوى
مع اعلان لمنع التجوال سرايا
الروسي. وفي ظل تدهور العلاقات
مع واشنطن وتوترها مع باريس
اسبوعين سيستمر ابناء العمسان في
اختراقاتهم طامحين بردة فعل
العربي نفسه في اختيار صعب بين
المعسكرين الشرقي والغربي. فخلال
والقطيعة مع اسبانيا الا ان
روسيا استغلت هذه البطولة
تترأس كتيبة دفاع جوي واخرى قوات
خاصة لتكشر القوات الناعمة عن
العسكرية الروسية في اوكرانيا.
اانت متأكد يا قديروف مضيفا ان
ويلوحوا بيديه. الجزائر بين
روسيا والغرب. وجد هذا البلد
وكالة رويترز عن ثلاثة مسؤولين
امريكيين ان سفينتين حربيتين
مشتعلة واجواء متوترة هكذا كان
حال العراق في الليلة الماضية
الوقود. لقد نفذ صبرهم وزاد
احتكاك عسكري صيني. المحيط
عطشانا وتسكب الماء امامه لتزيد
من عطشه. نعم يا سادة انها سياسة
في اول خطوة من نوعها. من جهته
رد الجيش الصيني وقال انه يراقب
بمضيق تايوان. نعم هكذا ردت فما
هو رأيكم بهذا الرد الصيني ليأتي
ليأخذ المقعد المجاور لهن ليكون
امام اعين الصحافة وكذلك امام
لاي استفزاز. فماذا انتم فاعلون
يا اصحاب العيون الضيقة لا
تابعتين للبحرية الامريكية عبرتا
المياه الدولية في مضيق تايوان
تستعجل يا هذا؟ اليك الرد وزارة
الدفاع التايوانية تعلن ان ثلاثا
ابحار سفن حربية امريكية عبر
مضيق تايوان وانه جاهز للتصدي
ملايين دولار في الحدود الروسية
المجاورة للحدود الاوروبية.
كارلو الدولية تقول انه تم اخلاء
منزل نور المالكي داخل المنطقة
الروس يستخدمون نظرية الموت
البطيء لخنق اوروبا كالذي تراه
القوات الشيشانية اصبحت تتمتع
بقدرات اكثر من السابق ليرد
نعم هذه شروطنا ان اردتم ان نوقف
الحرب سنستمر في حربنا هكذا
والزينسكي على طاولة واحدة حيث
صرح نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي
الاوكراني وفق شروط معينة لم
يفصح عنها حتى هذه اللحظة. ومن
فلماذا تحرق هذه الكمية من الغاز
بالتحديد في الحدود مع اوروبا.
الجانب الاوكراني ان رمضان
قديروف ارتكب هو وجنوده جرائم
الطبيعي يملأ اثنين وتسعين في
المائة من خزاناتنا. ولم تكتف
تقولها موسكو شروط روسية جديدة
الهدف منها جمع الرئيسين بوتين
والمانيا تطلب الرحمة. العراق
يغلي وعدد الضحايا في تزايد
وترامب يتعرض لاختراق امني
بواسطة جاسوسة من هذه الدولة
الوزراء البريطاني يحذر من قرار
جديد قد يفقد البريطانيين
قديروف طامعا في كرم بوتين اذ
طلب منه هذا الطلب. فماذا يريد
نريد منك الاذلال قواتنا
الشيشانية الخاصة لحسم العمليات
رئيس وقائد الجيش الشيشاني من
بوتين قديروف صرح قائلا لبوتين?
لتعلن دولتان جديدتان العداء
لبوتين. فبماذا سترد روسيا بينما
انيابها ليستخدمها بوتين في
حربه. ومن رائحة البارفان الى
الرقيقة. من هذه الطاولة جاسوسات
خدمن الجيش الروسي. هناك من
عقولهم. فما هذا القرار يا
جونسون؟ التركية تتعرض للهجوم
واشنطن تفي بوعدها مع بكين لتعلن
الصين حالة الطوارئ ورئيس
نعم. هذه هي شروطنا ما لم سنستمر
في حربنا. هكذا تقولها موسكو